envoyer des renforts
des coups de feu ont été tirés
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous sommes face à une
anomalie un adjoint de la police noir a
tiré sur un homme blanc qui n'était pas
armé est-ce que nous sommes là pour
rendre justice à l'homme blanc qui est
mort ou pour l'innocenter le policier
noir
qu'est ce qu'on a
pour américain entre 17 et 18 ans
il est mort
n'oubliez pas qu'ils recrutent et je
suis désolé mais juste un nom et vous
propose des robes voulez qu'on vous
réponde mieux aux et les mauvaises
questions
[Applaudissements]
je crois que baic est un bon flic dans
un mauvais département pour regrouper
les deux affaires celle qu'on nous a
attribué et celle à laquelle personne ne
le touche et ô combien de temps ça va
prendre bien madame vous voulez tout ça
bien opérer vite
j'attends de vous dire ça soit fait
piquer et bien non non non